avec vous Hélène frappe donc rebonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline dans la presse
les réactions au déba hier soir entré
manuel Macron et Marine Le Pen on
commence par la presse française un duel
sans concession le journal local le
télégram souligne ce matin les villes
échanges entre les deux candidats
notamment sur l'Europe et la Russie du
tacle au tacle Midi Libre jusque
Emmanuel Macron c'est montrer offensif
et précis face à une Marine Le Pen
combative et insistante l'un et l'autre
ne cédant rien à l'adversaire comme
lorsque le premier à qualifier la
seconde de climato-sceptique et que
celle-ci lui a rétorqué qu'il était à
climato hypothypocrite dans le duel qui
les a opposés Emmanuel Macron est passé
à l'attaque face à une Marine Le Pen en
défense mais qui serait resté pugnace
sur Harry Potter avec aisance selon Le
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
visiblement satisfait Pauline d'avoir
assisté hier un vrai débat le président
sortant à l'offensive comme s'il voulait
enfin jeter toutes ses forces dans la
bataille écrit le en évoquant une sorte
d'inversion des rôles par rapport à 2017
Emmanuel Macron qui pouvait craindre
d'être attaqué sans relâche sur son
bilan serait parvenu à placer sa
concurrente donc sur la défensive au
risque toutefois de brouiller sa
stratégie de campagne pour apparaître à
la fois plus humble et plus proche des
Français dans l'ensemble la presse
française donne toutefois un léger
avantage au président sortant Macron
domine mais Marine Le Pen tient le choc
estime le Figaro sensible à la sérénité
des armes affichées par Marine Le Pen un
dialogue 120 coeur par chaos mais
avantage au président confirme donc le
journal à propos de ce débat de tenue
correcte je cite mais sans garantie de
rester dans les annales autrement dit et
peut-être un peu terne sud-ouest estime
également que la candidate du RN se
retrouvait à plusieurs reprises en
difficulté alors que le président
sortant dit séquelles littéralement son
programme toujours pas au niveau 5 le
pour sa part libération d'après l'idée
Marine Le Pen effaçait voir brillante
incapable de s'imposer sur son sujet de
prédilection Line a évoqué le pouvoir
d'achat aurait manqué de répondant
peiner à garder la tête hors de l'eau
face à un adversaire au thon frôlant
l'arrogance flirtant entre la charité et
la condescendance mais qui se serait
liévré de son côté à un postif exercice
du militaire exercice qui laisse sur sa
fin une partie de la presse française
toutefois on a le Huffington Post parle
d'une mauvaise réplique de 2017 d'un
débat moins hostile sur la forme mais
dont les caractéristiques de fond
n'auraient pas pris une ride le tout
donnant à voir une prestation qui ne
devrait pas bouleverser le rapport de
force en faveur d'Emmanuel Macron comme
semble d'ailleurs en attester les
sondages à réaliser après ce débat des
échanges courtois pour ne pas dire
charmant venus par faire l'entreprise de
normalisation engagée depuis plusieurs
années par Marine Le Pen regrette le
site d'info Mediapart qui regrette
qu'Emmanuel Macron est employé à aucun
moment l'expression le terme
extrême droite ni dénoncé le racisme et
la xénophobie de son adversaire le tout
donnant lieu je cite à un grand moment
de dépolitisation et puis on va regarder
ce qu'on pense là après cette rangère je
vais vous laisser aller jusqu'au final
Le Pen vend la modération pour réduire
l'écart avec Macron titre et le païs
pour le quotidien espagnol la candidate
d'extrême droite a su résister et rester
dans le jeu en s'enveloppant dans le
drapeau tricolore et en exprimant à
plusieurs reprises son amour pour les
Français un amour qui peut faire un peu
peur de toutefois le journal sur de lui
Macron domine le Pen l'attribut de
Genève évoque de candidats faisant
tasseaux de sérieux mais cette fois tout
sourire évoluant dans une ambiance très
différente plus respectueuse qu'il y a 5
ans le soir lui a vu un débat à couteau
tiré dominé là encore par Emmanuel
Macron comme beaucoup de médias
étrangers le quotidien belge souligne
les attaques du président contre Marine
Le Pen accusé de dépendre du pouvoir
russe et de Monsieur Poutine tandis que
le Frankfurter algamin outsitung fait
état de la riposte de la candidate sur
le fait que l'Europe je la cite ne peut
pas se faire arakiri avec l'espoir de
faire du mal financièrement à la Russie
enfin de faire nonchal time joue les
juges de paix pas de chaos Marine Le Pen
garde son calme paradoxalement compte
tenu de son statut c'était Emmanuel
Macron qui a été le plus agressif Marine
Le Pen consciente de son agressivité
excessive en 2017 s'est montré plus
retenu et modéré bilan des courses pour
le quotidien britannique Pauline se
débat aura aidé manuel Macron à
consolider son avance sur sa rivale mais
cette course à la présidentielle
resterait malgré tout je cite
désagréablement serrés merci beaucoup
Hélène à très vite on se retrouve nous
juste après la pause à tout de suite
[Musique]